so i have to ask right off the bat why
do you think there aren't more canadians
part of the suicide squad are we just
too nice
you know i i think uh i think a lot of
people
see canadians as nice and maybe
to see that as a weakness kindness is
not a weakness
and you see it every time uh you know if
you've ever hung out with hockey players
and you start ribbing them and you start
ripping them and you start ribbing them
and they're cool
and they're cool when they've had enough
they shirt you and then they start doing
that
that hockey thing where they do that
kindness is not a weakness
you're just you're right you're just
edging towards the
the limit that's all you're doing is
edging towards the limit you just never
know absolutely right
it's unexpected but then watch out watch
those canadians
yeah um so i was dying when i found out
what
tbk stood for how did you react when you
found out
your your character and the super powers
well i was uh terribly misled first
james gunn told me tdk stood for
the dark knight so i was super excited
look out ben affleck here i come but
is not the case so now i now i see okay
you know that's the thing is uh i often
think what would powers
do to you if i had the power to control
time oh my gosh i would be just
i would be awful if i could teleport
that'd be the worst
power corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely
yes tdk has powers but he's not powerful
so i think his powers lead to his
vulnerability which is
uh his overconfidence he does not does
not belong
crack commandos we're going to come in
here and take care of business
he's a e team d team at best
oh my god i love it uh if there was a
suicide squad
buddy cop film and you had to pick
another character on this team
to start with who would it be who do you
think tdk would team up well with
i think uh javelin simply because uh
i think tdk would be a wonderful
straight man and
uh uh javelin thinks he's the straight
man
which is so bizarre because everybody
else is going oh jeez this guy i can't
even
and i think that's that's really
satisfying to watch people suffer and
just
because javelin oh boy that guy he's
just so clueless
about being clueless i love it well
that's where all the comedy comes from
just so much fun okay if everybody was
together on this team
who do you think king sharp would eat
first
jesus you know peacemaker right just to
stop the yapping
and after after that maybe he wouldn't
eat anybody for a little while because
that's
that's a big meal that's like you're
starting with the so i guess it's a
matter of how hungry is he
that's the question i love that you know
and just wrapping things up obviously
you're in slither so i'm assuming at
this point nothing surprises you when it
comes to a script but
was there ever a time when you're
reading this that you're like how are
they going to get away with shooting
this
i yes yes uh it was page 15.
i was page 15 of the script and i went
oh my god
you son of a [ __ ]
i love that perfect thank you so much
it's so nice getting to chat with you
pleasure morgan thanks very much
you